how much of what i like
what you like is what you like versus
what's being sold to us
for example let me go a little deeper no
matter how many skinny models i saw on
calvin klein
i was never turned on by right you know
what i'm saying so i saw
me this is what you're supposed to look
like like a zoolander looking you're
you know looking like it never did
nothing to me i was almost like can i
get you a double whopper right now go
eat a big mac please
eat some pizza and put some weight on
you're 95 pounds you look like you're
about to
break if i even touch you like i'm
worried about touching here right
so how much of it is
us believing in the dream that's being
sold from media
from politicians from our clergy from
our parents where
you know kids parents tell them you know
a good man
is somebody who believes in god and
lives a godly life a good man is
somebody that
takes care of themselves honey you have
to look sexy put on the right makeup or
you know you got to go serve the
military because it's that you got to
have
you got to work hard you know you got to
really work hard all these things that
we go through
organize clean athlete my dad loves
football i'm going to go be a football
player to make him proud
how much of it is the marketing being
done around us by media tv parents
military all that stuff and how much of
it is actually us yeah i mean great so
if i were to rephrase your your question
i would say you're in a sense if i
distill it it's you're asking about the
nature versus nurture
issue right how much of who we are is
due to nature genes
how much of it is due to nurture you
know all the things that you mentioned
well and the best way for me to answer
that i'm not trying to do a cop-out
answer it's really the true scientific
answer
so i'm gonna use a metaphor here so if
you take
all of the ingredients of a cake you
take the butter you take the eggs
you take the flour you take the baking
soda
each of those ingredients are separate
right before i bake the cake once i bake
the cake
and now i show you the final cake if i
were to tell you
patrick please point to the eggs you
couldn't it's an inextricable mix
patrick please point to the sugar
so we are that cake we are an
inextricable
melange mix of our genes and our
environments now
depending on the phenomenon you ask me
about it might tilt more towards nature
or nurture my height is driven a lot
more by my nature
than my nurture no amount of hugging and
coddling by my parents
would have turned me into a six foot six
basketball player
so it depends so so the best answer i
can give you is it depends
some things are almost exclusively
nature some
are largely due to nurture but most are
somewhere in the middle i hope that i've
given you a satisfactory answer so if
you like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye